A person is chased down a dark
hallway by a monster with large claws.]
What does a monster look like to you?
What figures slither and claw their way into
your nightmares, chasing you down endless
halls and stalking you through the dark until
you wake up screaming?
Maybe you imagine something tall and lean,
bony arms reaching for you from atop impossibly
long, slender legs, its featureless face showing
no mercy
Maybe you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers , or a serial killer
in a hockey mask, wielding a machete.
Maybe it’s something more inhuman, a cosmic
horror of tentacles and eyes that can see
into your very soul.
You probably don’t think of something with
no arms, no legs, no body at all.
Just a face.
What’s so scary about that?
A face can’t run after you, can’t grab
you by the ankles and pull you under the bed.
A face can only look.
It may be unsettling to behold, it might send
a chill down your spine, but the worst it
can do is make you a little uncomfortable.
And if you can’t stand it any longer, you
could always just close your eyes, or walk
away and be done with it.
Right?
If that’s what you think, if you don’t
believe in monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger, then you’re the type to
fall victim to a very special, very intelligent
mask.
In the hallowed halls of the SCP Foundation,
there is a containment cell outfitted with
a hermetically sealed glass case, surrounded
by steel, iron, and lead.
There are guards posted outside, along with
a trained psychologist.
If you are ever brave, and foolish, enough
to enter that room, you’ll see a simple
white porcelain comedy mask, with a peculiar
black substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth.
Wherever this slime touches, surfaces begin
to corrode, to rot away into puddles of black
liquid.
You might notice the same liquid trickling
slowly down the walls of the room, corrupting
everything in its path.
As unsettling of a sight as it is, if you
approach the mask to take a closer look, you
will find yourself overcome by an intense,
nearly irresistible urge to pick it up, and
put it on.
To wear it, to let it consume you from the
inside out and puppet your body while your
brain simply…turns off.
Like an extinguished flame, you’ll simply
be gone.
Then, who knows what the mask will do?
It won’t be your concern anymore, that’s
for sure.
But thankfully, you haven’t gone into the
room with the porcelain mask.
You haven’t let it cast its spell on you.
Not yet, at least.
It’s waiting for you there, in the room
with black slime oozing down its walls.
And it will wait patiently, for as long as
it needs to.
After all, what’s a mask without a face
to wear it?
SCP-035, better known as the Possessive Mask,
sat in its containment cell, immobile as always.
It didn’t really have much of a choice in
the matter.
The Foundation had chosen, selfishly, to revoke
its host privileges.
Once upon a time, they had offered it bodies
to choose from, mannequins, dummies, and wooden
dolls it could adorn and pilot.
They didn’t last as long as an organic,
living host, of course.
But it was something.
It was a taste of freedom.
This dreadful new situation was almost enough
to make the mask want
to change its
expression from comedy to tragedy, but it
was determined to still find something to
laugh about.
Even without a body, trapped in this infernal
box, there had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment.
Human minds were fragile things.
The mask had learned this over the infinite
years of its life, if one could call it a
life.
Apply the right kind of pressure to the right
weak points, whisper an enticing word or two,
find the right emotional wound to sprinkle
a pinch of salt into, and humans would buckle
completely in almost no time at all.
It had tried all sorts of methods since being
confined to this boring little box.
Sometimes it would charm someone, pour honeyed
flattery into their heads until the person
felt like the mask was a dear friend, a confidante.
Once suitable trust had been built up, the
mask could persuade the person to bring it
a host, or perhaps even offer up themselves
in sacrifice.
If flattery didn’t work, there were other
potent approaches to take.
For a being without ears, the mask was a good
listener.
It picked up on things that no human ever
could, the darkest secrets buried in a person’s
mind.
If it caught wind of something especially
juicy and ruinous, it could leverage that.
Threaten to expose an affair, a crime, or
perhaps something even worse.
Something unspeakable.
If praise failed, and so did blackmail, there
was always good old supernatural intimidation.
All the mask needed was for someone to be
left alone with it for a long enough period
of time.
Then, its invisible tendrils could snake out
into their defenseless mind, weaving and poking
around, leaving a lingering sense of cold,
dread, of incomprehensible whispers in long-dead
tongues.
What a delight containment had been in the
early days, when the Foundation had not yet
figured out the mask’s true capabilities.
When they would leave security personnel with
weak wills and minimal training standing guard
in the mask’s field of influence for hours
at a time, as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free will.
It had almost escaped more than once, thanks
to the helpers it had been able to mold out
of those hapless victims.
They had been there to break open its case
and carry it to freedom.
But every time, the other guards thwarted
the attempts, shooting its helpers and rendering
them utterly useless.
Then, the Foundation increased its security.
Something about the unacceptably high suicide
and homicide rates among staff assigned to
SCP-035.
How utterly boring.
How truly…pathetic.
Still, the mask had found ways to occupy itself
even without any more playthings.
It had grown stronger with its boredom, stretching
its influence beyond organic beings and into
the very room itself, its evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the depths of
a cold cellar.
Over the months, the walls of SCP-035’s
containment cell had begun to secrete the
same black, slimy substance that would pour
from the mask’s eyes and mouth.
The liquid dripped down the walls in deliberate
formations, patterns that became increasingly
easy to recognize.
Phrases in Italian, Latin, Ancient Greek,
all detailing ritual sacrifices and mutilations.
The mask took time to describe the sacrificial
victims in great detail, borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that it
knew would read the translations.
The walls were slick with blood and harrowing
imagery, and the glass case around the mask
was growing more and more fragile by the day.
Anyone within 10 meters of the mask could
feel this strength, too.
They would leave the area complaining of unintelligible
whispers, of loud, cruel laughter, and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair.
It was as if they knew, on some level, that
no one was truly safe.
Eventually, the mask would find a way to come
for them all.
The glass was weakening, and soon the mere
thought of escape would make it shatter into
pieces.
Then, perhaps, the mask could finally get
its deepest desire: revenge.
It wanted nothing more than to make the Foundation
pay for imprisoning it, for taking away its
host privileges, for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should have
had them falling to their knees in worship.
The mask seethed with hatred day in and day
out.
It had seen the crumbling of the Roman Empire,
the beheading of kings, the decimation of
armies.
It was not going to be captured by a bunch
of rats in lab coats without dire consequences
befalling them.
Maybe it couldn’t move from its prison cell
at the moment, but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous beasts
capable of reducing the site, and all who
had dared to oppose the mask, to a pile of
smoldering rubble.
If it could only find its way onto one of
their faces…it would show them all just
what it was capable of.
As the piercing sound of an alarm echoed down
the hall, the sound of screams and chaos following
shortly after, the mask’s frowning face
curved into a broad, menacing smile.
What was it that had escaped?
The lizard, perhaps?
The giant, grinning man?
Whatever it was, it seemed that the action
was heading right toward 035’s containment
cell.
Perhaps today was the day.
Finally, the SCP Foundation would fall.
Outside the mask’s cell, Security Officer
Harper was running for dear life.
Though his more rational mind knew he was
living on seconds, not even minutes, of borrowed
time, his animal brain kept his legs pumping
- desperately trying to avoid the screaming,
howling predator hot on his heels.
Harper looked over his shoulder and screamed
as a long, white arm reached for him.
SCP-096: The Shy Guy, its tooth-lined jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle.
That face, that terrible, terrible face - an
absolute death sentence to all who saw it.
He’d seen what he thought was a crack in
the otherwise perfect seal of 096’s containment
chamber, but it could have just as easily
been a trick of the light.
Not even thinking, he’d stepped forward
and looked at the vulnerability in the chamber.
All it took was one misplaced ray of light,
and he made out the vague shape of a face
in the darkness.
That’s when the weeping started.
Harper knew, in that moment, his life was
over.
The correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close their
eyes while he stood there and accepted his
fate, minimizing the risk of spreading the
damage further.
But humans rarely have perfect reasoning,
even less so when facing mortality.
Back in the present, the Shy Guy made a perfect
lunge, grabbing Harper in its iron clutches
and barreling through the adjoining wall.
The nearby guards scattered, terrified, keeping
their eyes on the floor.
They might get a slap on the wrist for temporarily
abandoning their posts, but they weren’t
going to die guarding some stupid evil mask.
Speaking of, the possessive mask was surprised
to feel two new presences enter its chamber
- through the now-destroyed wall.
These two presences soon became just one,
as SCP-096 quickly and totally annihilated
Security Officer Harper, leaving nothing left.
The mask couldn’t see, per se, seeing as
it had no actual sensory organs, but it felt
around this new guest with its many psychic
tendrils, taking in its strange totality.
The creature was powerful, no doubt about
that, and it elicited fear from those fools
at the SCP Foundation, but the mask noticed
its brainwaves were extraordinarily muted.
Humans, to the mask’s vast and malicious
consciousness, weren’t the sharpest knives
in the drawer, but compared to this thing’s
mind, they were a pile of tempered katanas.
It barely thought at all.
The mask would have to dig deeper to find
anything it could use…
Meanwhile, SCP-096 finally began to calm down.
The one who had seen it had been annihilated.
Bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out and
replaced by the standard low but constant
hum of anxiety and despair.
It would simply wait until its head was bagged
and it was dragged back to the dark.
Same old, same old, all the way to the end
of time.
That’s when it felt something else.
It started as a faint buzz, an unintelligible
whisper.
Then, it was almost like a door opened in
the back of its head, Something stepped in
and took a seat.
Can you hear me, stranger?
Knock knock.
I want to speak to you…
Something about the voice frightened and comforted
SCP-096 at the same time.
It spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
than the creature had heard in a long time,
and yet, something about the way it spoke
implied evil in its intent.
I know what you want.
I know what you fear.
Wouldn’t it be nice if they could never
look at you again?
If you could cover that face of yours?
I can help you.
It will be so simple.
All you need to do is put me on…
Little by little, 096 felt more of these strange
thoughts filling up the emptiness in its head,
replacing the few thoughts the creature itself
had.
It felt itself lifting its hands from the
ground, lifting them and reaching towards
something - A glass box.
The glass shattered and those long, white
fingers reached for something within.
A mask.
Just like the voice had said.
A mask to stop people from looking at its
face…
Yes, yes, you’re doing so well.
You’re so close.
Just a little further…
SCP-096 lifted the mask to its face, feeling
black liquid that burned its skin dripping
from the porcelain, and put it on.
And in that moment, everything changed.
The Shy Guy’s body began to seize up, rattling
as the mask unleashed a web of psychic tendrils
through its body, mapping out across every
inch like a new nervous system, taking control.
The Possessive Mask had never experienced
a host like this before - That incredible,
perfect mix of physical durability and a mind
so insubstantial that it was easy to sublimate.
Oh, this was going to be fun…
For the first time, the Shy Guy - now under
the full control of the Possessive Mask - stood
at full height on its hind legs, its spine
and shoulders clicking into place for its
new stance.
The Mask cracked its neck, getting used to
the new dimensions of its physicality.
Its indestructible bones.
Its long, grasping limbs.
Its skin, burning and fizzling with the gooey
black secretions, but growing back just as
quickly.
The Foundation had every reason to fear it
now.
A group of security personnel had gathered
in the ragged hole where the chamber’s north
wall used to be.
Some were wielding light firearms; the guard
at the front was carrying an opaque black
bag.
The Mask laughed with its new body and turned
to the crowd.
The second they saw it on 096’s body, their
faces fell.
For a moment, their bodies went slack with
terror.
This situation was unprecedented.
What course of action could they possibly
take at a time like this?
It looked at the bag held by the leader of
the security force and projected a single
thought into his mind: You won’t be needing
that.
Before any of the guards even had a chance
to open fire, the Mask lunged forwards, using
the long, terrible arms of the Shy Guy to
tear through the guards.
They were dead in seconds, their bodies strewn
about the hallway.
The mask’s porcelain was twisted into a
wide, sadistic grin.
It could tell that it was about to have some
real fun around here - and once it’d slaughtered
everyone here, it could finally stretch its
legs out in the open again.
True freedom to spread misery, fear, and pain
everywhere it went.
There were just a few hundred members of Foundation
personnel it needed to turn into corpses,
first.
More containment breach alarms sounded around
the site as the Mask began its rampage, running
through the hallways and tearing apart any
unfortunate Foundation personnel it could
get 096’s hands on.
Guards, researchers, administrative staff,
and even one extremely unlucky janitor in
Hallway C6.
It was having the time of its long and terrible
life, and much to its glee, it seemed that
this new host’s body was still holding up.
It was perfect symbiosis - A twisted, brilliant
mind and a body that could forever support
it.
There would be no stopping it, a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around the
site soon realized on their own terms.
096 was indestructible, but it was dumb as
a brick and had an easily exploitable weakness:
Get the bag on its head and you’re home
free.
This new composite creature was a different
story.
It could think tactically, avoiding head-on
confrontations in favor of sneak attacks,
and the monster had as much psychic combat
potential as physical.
Guards roving the building in teams, heavily
armed, with anti-memetic protective gear,
still reported feeling immense feelings of
psychological dread over comms.
That was the greatest sign that The Mask would
come bursting through the wall moments later
and tear them to shreds.
The Site Director put out an urgent call for
all nearby Mobile Task Forces to intercept
and help them take care of the unfolding situation.
Thankfully, a detachment of MTF Eta-10, also
known as "See No Evil", was operating on a
case in close proximity.
Given their specialization in anomalies with
a memetic visual property, many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before.
That at least gave them experience in half
of this situation.
And one operative among them, Sergeant Henrique
Ramirez, would be the one to bring this nightmare
to an end.
But it would cost him his life in the process.
The Mask was still using its new indestructible
body to wreak havoc on the containment site.
Once it had taken out the primary contingents
of guards, it was free to have its fun with
the rest: Stalking defenseless researchers
through the halls, making sure to induce maximum
terror before finally striking the killing
blow.
Every single one of them died with a head
full of demonic whispers - it told them of
the Mask’s eternal dominion.
Now, it had found the perfect host, nothing
on earth would stop it.
Humans would be mere ants under its feet.
Eta-10 touched down and entered the building.
Ramirez was point man, leading the others
into the bowels of the blood-drenched containment
site.
They’d been briefed on what they were heading
in for: 096 and 035 had reached symbiosis
and were displaying unprecedented anomalous
effects.
Enter with extreme caution - They’re beyond
dangerous, even more so together than alone.
Ideally, Ramirez would have wanted to go in
with a comprehensive plan, but lives were
on the line here.
They needed to leap off the cliff and build
their wings on the way down.
It was only when they finally encountered
the monster that they realized just how outmatched
they were.
Despite their best efforts, the combined speed,
intelligence, and ferocity of the Mask’s
new form allowed it to make short work of
Eta-10.
Only Ramirez was left, heavily injured.
Even if a miracle happened, he knew he wasn’t
getting out of here alive.
The Mask grabbed him with one of 096’s claws
and lifted him up.
It would take its time with this one.
Make him suffer.
Watch him squirm.
Destroy his mind.
Ramirez felt the Mask’s psychic tendrils
penetrate the membrane of his mind.
Those whispers, those terrible whispers, reciting
all his worst fears with terrible glee.
His gun was out of ammo.
His knife was broken.
All he had left on him was a pocket mirror.
And that was his eureka moment.
It was a long shot, but it was also his only
shot.
He reached out and grabbed the bottom of the
mask, pulling for dear life.
His other hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror, opening its lid with a deft flick
of his thumb.
It was all too fast for the Mask to even register
what was going on.
Ramirez forced his eyes shut and lifted up
the mirror.
The Mask saw its own reflection in the glass,
as the bottom of its face came loose, revealing
the reflection of the face underneath.
The Mask squeezed, killing Ramirez, but it
was already too late.
It had finally seen the face of its host,
and that would cost it dearly.
The Mask felt a sudden and tremendous pushback
to its psychic forces - A blind despair and
then rage that choked out everything.
SCP-096 began to sob and howl.
Somehow, the Mask was no longer in control.
Despite its psychic protests, 096 reached
up and tore the terrible mask from its face,
tossing it against the wall with such force
that it was embedded in the brickwork.
Its last thoughts, as other Mobile Task Force
operators descended on the area to bag 096
and return it to its containment chamber,
were: What the hell just happened?
And the next thought that crossed the mind
of the Site Director was, “Request site
transfer for 035 as soon as possible.
Don’t want a repeat of this incident any
time soon…”
Now go check out “SCP-035 - The Possessive
Mask” and “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE - Incident
096-1-A Containment Breach” for more videos
on today’s terrifying combatants!